So the consequences of understanding a new market are essential for a startup.
This was a startup killer for decades.
In a new market, there are no customers, so revenues might extend out for years.
In fact, if you think about what happened during the dot-com bubble,
in the beginning of the 21st century is every startup executed like they were in an existing market.
They hired sales people, they spent marketing dollars, and in scale of tens of millions or dollars
trying to create and use your demands for a market that didn't exist.
Just imagine what would've happened if those start-ups would've parked their capital in a bank
getting interest and doing ??? activities to help start the market because the market wasn't there.
There is no way any individual startup can accelerate technology diffusion.
So for a new market to take off, lots of things external to your startup need to happen.
Regulation needs to change. Platforms need to become cheaper.
Customer cases need to change, etc.
The dot-com bubble was actually predicated on all these things happening all at once
and they didn't, and therefore, all that money that got raised
got spent trying to acquire customers when they were none.
The test for whether you're in a new market is not whether 30 people in your regional cluster,
or in Silken Valley, or New York have heard about your technology.
The real test is whether your grandmother in Omaha or Berlin or in Uganda
actually have heard about the technology or the product or the market.
And if the market doesn't exist there, you might be spending a lot of money
trying to create a market where there is none.
Premature spending is the killer for startups.